[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es ein
gesundes schnelles und einfaches
Mittagessen für euch wir machen Chicken
Curry in kokosoße und Reis dazu den Reis
habe ich hier allerdings schon
vorbereitet da gibt es schon ein Basic
Video auf meinem Kanal dafür nehmt ihr
euch einfach den das mal die
Langkornreis unter fließendem Wasser die
Stärke ausspülen bis das Wasser fast
klar wieder rauskommt und dann in etwas
Öl anrösten so dass ein paar Röstaromen
entstehen mit kochendem Wasser
übergießen salzen und dann runter auf
die Stufe 3 und mit dazu geschlossenem
Deckel einfach vor sich hin garen der
Grund warum ich den Reis jetzt als
erstes mache ist der dass das Gericht so
schnell ist dass wir dann quasi nicht
auf den Reis warten möchten ich habe
jetzt hier Hähnchenbrust das werde ich
jetzt einfach im mundgerechte Stücke
teilen und dann schon in der Pfanne
anbraten dann nehme ich einfach so ein
bisschen Rapsöl und dann stelle ich
stufe ich möchte immer wenn ich die
Stufe mit dazu sage die Stufe stelle ich
zu Beginn auf 8 von 9 einfach damit ich
das relativ scharf anbraten und gehe
dann später runter wenn die weiteren
Zutaten dazu kommen
[Musik]
sobald ihr das Hähnchen scharf
angebraten habt mit der Stufe ein
bisschen runter und Zwiebeln und
Knoblauch mit dazugeben das darf dann
noch mal schön mit anrösten fällt auch
so ein bisschen dann in sich zusammen
und das Hähnchen ist schön scharf
angebraten von außen so jetzt kommen die
Gewürze mit dazu ich habe hier
verschiedene Gewürze und zwar einmal
Kreuzkümmel das ist für mich persönlich
ein muss allein schon geschmacklich
finde ich mega und gleich kommen ja auch
noch Kichererbsen mit dazu und allein
schon um den Kichererbsen so ein
bisschen auf blinde Wirkung manchmal
wenn manche Menschen und Kreuzkümmel
wirkt da einfach entgegen daher nicht
nur geschmacklich super sondern halt
auch macht einfach sinnlicher Erbsen
dabei sind hier habe ich noch Garam
Masala finde ich persönlich auch mega
lecker könntet ihr notfalls noch
weglassen ihr braucht aber auf jeden
Fall einen currywurz da gibt's ja
verschiedene Gewürzmischungen ich habe
hier z.B unser Bollywood Express das ist
so ein bisschen ich würde sagen scharf
aber ein bisschen schärfer als unser
Dach und Curry ist auch ein Curry Gewürz
es gibt ja unendliche und ich schreibe
euch alles ganz genau unten in die
Infobox daher braucht ihr euch das jetzt
nicht merken so ein bisschen Kurkuma
noch für die Farbe
so dann nehme ich jetzt noch mal einen
neuen Löffel und zum Schluss noch
Paprika edelsüß davon gebe ich jetzt
nicht zu wenig mit dazu
Stichwort Paprika kommt gleich auch noch
Paprika mag mit dazu könnt ihr auch
jetzt schon dazu geben das gibt nämlich
zusammen mit den Gewürzen noch schöne
Röstaromen deswegen gehe ich jetzt auch
gleich wieder hoch auf die Stufe sechs
und lass das noch mal so ein bisschen
anrösten und was jetzt natürlich ganz
zum Schluss nicht fehlen lassen ganz
normales Salz und Pfeffer das gebe ich
jetzt noch mit dazu und dann lass ich
das so ein bisschen die Röstaromen
entfalten
[Musik]
das jetzt riechen könntet es riecht
unfassbar lecker das ganze wird jetzt
eigentlich nur noch gepimpt mit Gemüse
also alles was sie so da habt ich hatte
jetzt wie gesagt noch Kichererbsen aus
der Dose da die sind ja dann schon
eingeweicht das heißt die kann ich
direkt hier mit dazu schmeißen macht
auch noch mal schön satt und Möhren habe
ich da damit einfach mein
wellenschneider benutzt verlinke ich
euch in die Infobox gibt's bei mir im
Shop genauso wie alle anderen Dinge die
ich so verwende die lasse ich euch gerne
in der Infobox da und das verrühre ich
jetzt hier noch mal ganz kurz und lösche
das mit einer Dose Kokosmilch ab
manchmal ist die Kokosmilch übrigens
oben total fest und dann setze ich das
ganze Kokoswasser unten ab das ist ganz
normal am besten vorher gut durchrühren
oder einfach so reingeben sobald es
schmilzt dann ist es dann total schön
flüssig und cremig das ganze jetzt noch
einmal miteinander verrühren und mit
geschlossenem Deckel so fünf sechs
sieben Minuten lang köcheln lassen in
der Zeit wird dann auch die Möhre so ein
bisschen weicher und alles wird schön
zart und dann ist das Gericht auch schon
fertig so schnell ging das meine lieben
[Musik]
du kriegst wirklich so deine
Kupferschale mit Essen Reis für die
Mitte ist immer so lustig mit dem
Internet denkt man immer oha wie soll
der Reis reichen das ist so viel zu
wenig ist es immer zu viel
sein ehrlich
enttäuscht weil die wenn du wirklich
indischen Reis mal kochst ne und
gewonnen
ist eigentlich so ein bisschen wie
afghana Iran auch mit dem Reis ist
richtig drauf und dann gehst du dahin
und hast du so gefühlt so hält kein Held
mehr aber kein Gefühl im Deutschen Reich
von der Kantine
haben gesagt jetzt ne aber das hier das
riecht schon so
Mango nein aber ich liebe Mango chicken
habe ich auch ein Rezept mit meinem
Kanal das riecht aber das riecht am nach
baller chicken mit Kokos ja das ist auf
jeden Fall Kokosmilch drin
ist doch keine Butter drin der ist so
wer den süßlichen Touch mag kann auch
Honig ganz am Ende reinmachen mag ich
auch sehr gerne
meine Lieben ich habe nicht mehr als 25
Minuten gebraucht also es ist auch ein
sehr sehr schnelles Rezept muss ich
sagen
wenn ich das so sehe und riecht und
jetzt so und Ganzen sehe das machst du
sehr oft deswegen
habe ich auch immer im Kühlschrank ich
bin gerade mit diesem Wellenschnitt
sieht das auch richtig cool aus also
hübsch
praktisch gut
gebrauchen
machen gerne ein bisschen
ich bin nicht so der scharfan ehrlich
gesagt aber es ist sehr lecker ist auch
nicht so ölig ja
haben wir auch mal sehr gerne
Mittagessen Abendessen passt immer geht
immer und geht auch wirklich sehr sehr
schnell und ihr könnt das auch wenn ihr
zum Beispiel vegetarisch haben möchtet
Hähnchen auch mal durch Tofu ersetzen
schmeckt auch sehr lecker mache ich dann
haben sie nicht da haben sie zu den Tofu
Fan
zubereiten also
bis zum nächsten Mal
und vergiss es like nicht und gerne auch
einen Kommentar welches herzhafte Rezept
sehen möchtet das sieht voll aus finde
ich geil angehört aber was nicht schreib
mal einen Kommentare also rein ne jetzt
sofort also bis dann ciao
[Musik]